Egypt's president Abdel Fattah al-sisi
again called for a UN resolution on
Libya he says a failure to act now will
only make the situation worse would the
minute I will Manhattan if you want
Libya could turn into a breeding ground
that will threaten the whole region and
Europe the mission was left unfinished
by our European friends she abandoned
the Libyan people as prisoners to
extremist malicious rival governments
have been battling for control since
2011 Egypt supports that internationally
recognized government based in the
eastern city of Tobruk a rival Islamist
government is operating in the
traditional capital Tripoli jihadists
have used the political chaos to expand
their presence in the country Cairo
hasn't waited for a UN mandate on Monday
the Egyptian Air Force bombed Islamic
state targets in Libya that came in
response to the release of a video
showing Egyptian Coptic Christians being
beheaded by is supporters in the country
al-sisi says he hopes the ultimate
outcome will be a stable government in
control of Libya self Olivia had two
aborted